well guys it is a lovely day today we've
taken the kids out of school early and
we're going to go down and camp on the
beach and fish for giant halibut fishing
for halibut off the beach is a really
unusual way to catch halibut here in
alaska so i'm really excited to give it
a try my buddy jake with the youtube
channel how to alaska
uh is going to meet up with us and he's
been doing it up quite a bit and he's
going to show us the ropes so it's gonna
be fun
hey
[Music]
yeah
got some beautiful alaskan weather here
yeah you guys catching some bait
check it out fake food that's crazy this
is a hooligan little fish that comes in
from the ocean every spring and to spawn
up in the rivers kind of like a little
mini oily salmon
so that'll be great halibut bait
oh you got a couple in there i have
three but one
[Applause]
well guys this weather is terrible i'm
going back in the car
all right you guys get in there
well it is cold and wet out there but
they're tearing up the hooligan we'll
have plenty of bait
going out
hooligan hands they're so cold they're
so cold it is cold out there
all right we're gonna follow jake and
his family down to their secret halibut
spot here
jake pulled over and got a shovel in his
cooler out they're gonna go dig ice up
gotta watch out for that yellow snow
oh look at the bald eagles there's like
four of them
they're fighting you need to gather up
firewood get a fire pit going so we're
on the kenai peninsula and we're going
to go surf fishing for halibut now
halibut can get up to 400 pounds and
it's really unusual to catch them from
shore they're usually fished for in one
to 400 feet of water kind of a deep
water species but it is spring and fall
they come in shallow and we might get a
chance to catch some really nice fish
fabulous fabulous eating fish
[Music]
well my third rod has a bunch of
problems with the reel so i'm only using
two rods but we're gonna let that sit
i'm gonna start getting dinner ready you
guys having fun
it's another day at the beach here in
alaska oh no
we got flying fights that's ahead
you're enjoying this yeah it's nice and
warm in here it's cold out
all right love you babe
i'm gonna use the car as a bit of a
windbreak
[Music]
all right guys everyone grab a bowl
grab a spoon
yeah the better i'm doing
without having to put a juggle a rod or
you know
all right guys i'm gonna try making a
little rice pudding here at the leftover
rice
we're just holding out
some hot rice pudding on a cold day
it's getting about the kids bedtime so
we need to start getting their sleeping
bags and everything situated
but um i think we're gonna have a
problem with the tide being too high so
we can't pitch a tent right here so i'm
gonna go ahead and try to set up tent in
the back of the truck
so the boys can go to sleep even if
we're gonna fish late
gosh
all right guys you're good
yeah if you need anything bang on the
window okay or if you need to get out
just push open this box okay
love you guys
well guys we've been at it all day but
no bites just been fighting wind and
waves but it's late my wife has been a
very good sport so i think it's time to
reel it up and go make camp we got a lot
of fishing we can do tomorrow all right
i got the tent set up and the boys
tucked inside into bed it's late i gotta
go to sleep i'll see you guys in the
morning
ugh
well originally we planned on camping
right by our fishing rods all night long
but turns out there was a really high
tide so we ended up going and retreating
to the sand dunes and camping there to
avoid getting wet in the middle of the
night
but uh now it's morning we're gonna go
back to our fishing spot
and jake's already there and set up and
we're gonna go see if we can't catch a
halibut we're gonna try fishing all day
do you like strudels
all right go eat some of those
and there's little calculators you can
do well we finished breakfast and the
tides changed and now it's coming in
hopefully that means the bite will turn
on and uh we'll catch ourselves some
lunch
that looks like a agate like a little
bit of quartz right there
we get really extreme tides here we had
about a 25 foot tide last night the
water went almost to the toe of the
bluff
but with the water out it's exposed a
lot of semi-precious stones there's
jasper and agates and quartz
all over this beach and the boys are
going bonkers trying to find
semi-precious stones
i told tommy he can polish him up if he
gathers up a bunch of them
well we've been fishing all morning and
it's about noon just nobody's caught
anything or had any bites so we're gonna
go try a different beach
[Music]
well we're here at this new beach and
it's about an hour before high tide
so it's the golden hour oh the weather's
so much better here it's not quite as
windy it's a little bit warmer
oh look at that guaranteed bite yeah
chomped it right in two didn't he yeah
he did
[Music]
now this is a skate it's a member of the
shark family and even though it looks
like a stingray it's not it's got little
spines on its tail but no poisonous
barbs man he's trying to get you with
that tail yeah he's trying to scare me
off but he's scared
that's its gills right there oh the
there we go there we go
whoa watch that tail
some people eat skate but we're not
really into that so we uh threw him back
hopefully we'll get a halibut here a
little bit
but hey we're not skunked
it's a stringer of hooligans
a little soul little flounder i'm a soul
man
joked that hard so i think i'm gonna
take this moment to try to cook some
dinner
we got shish kebabs
it's a little baby skate
something
[Music]
[Applause]
they're coming top
hey
what do you think was that fun yes first
halibut off the beach
and very disturbing
oh yeah it sprayed blood all over your
coat
you look like an axe murderer
i think we might be getting one on this
other rod too tom
hey don't worry he's got a ways to go
oh
fine doggy that is a spine dog fish look
at that wicked horn they got on the back
that's a dog shark look at that
all of a sudden things got interesting
and it's getting time to go i gotta pull
up these rods and we gotta get some
halibut cooked up
especially the bradford the backbone
there i do
so we're going to do go roll these in
panko and deep fry it yep
[Applause]
what you got
oh big old sculpin
look at that thick
look at all that sand in your nose
mmm all right good cocktail sauce
jake actually made the cocktail sauce
from scratch here that's nice if i
haven't mentioned already jake has his
own youtube channel how to alaska we've
done a lot of videos together and he's
got some awesome stuff on his channel
check it out i'll put a link in the
video description below
look you need to try that did you like
it yeah it's really good
you can't get much fresher than eating
halibut on the beach you caught it yeah
well listen jake thanks so much for
taking this fish in and cooking up this
wonderful fish oh man my pleasure
if i would have slept
it's a regular pancake cody you guys
dress safe all right thank you
i see you guys
did you guys have fun yeah
well listen guys we have a long trip
home so we're gonna say goodbye to you
guys and we will see you next saturday
morning don't forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos every saturday
morning
nailed it
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching